well let's cross to our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone who joins us
now live and Mark it was expected that
he was going to announce that he would
run again but this is a man who will be
86 by the end of a second term it's it's
quite an undertaking
it is and I think that is the key
concern I mean clearly his age is an
attack point for Republicans um who
think he's useless for Democrats
um they recognize that many Democrats
recognized that he has been a successful
as they see it first term uh president
he has steadied the ship after a very
turbulent uh years as they would see it
under Donald Trump legislatively
domestically he has done extremely well
better than any president for many many
years the economy is in good shape but
then there are there are fundamental key
concerns as well like like um abortion
access like guns um like the economy and
the direction it could go in inflation
and then overriding all of that for
Democrats too is his age 82 he would be
at the time of re-election and nearer 90
at the end of his uh second term if he
were to win now I I've observed him
we've been watching his speeches that
he's given recently compared them with
speeches he's given just a few years ago
he is older there's no denying that he
is less fluent he is a little less able
physically I mean that's only natural
but he clearly believes that doesn't
matter he Billy believes he has the
ability to be Ableton this country to
delegate where he needs to and that he
is I guess almost the father figure of
the country and I think that's what this
video is intending to do um there is
there's so much repeated in this video
from the one which he released precisely
four years ago today when he first told
Americans that he wanted to be their
president he's using some of the same
language he's
talking about a battle for the soul of
the nation he's
repeatedly referencing if not by name
Donald Trump the man who believe it or
not and many people around the world
might find it a surprise to think that
Donald Trump could be a candid again
believe me he could he probably will be
the Republican candidate and so what Joe
Biden is doing is pitting himself
against Donald Trump just as he did four
years ago and why does he believe he is
the man to to run the country for
another four years well because he knows
that he beat Donald Trump last time and
he therefore thinks that he can do it
again
um the tweet from Joe Biden which was
released just eight minutes ago I have
to say it's very early here in
Washington DC we expected it might
happen a little later today but they've
got in there for the morning shows right
at the start of of this Tuesday morning
he said every generation has a moment
where they have to stand up for
democracy to stand up for their
fundamental freedoms I believe this is
ours that's why I'm running for
re-election as president of the United
States States join us let us finish the
job that I think will be his his
um his slogan over the course of the the
next 18 months or so finish the job he
believes his supporters believe they've
done a lot over the past four years who
wants to be a one-term president not Joe
Biden he reckons he can do it again but
the polling Jane is not good a weekend
Poll for NBC News uh our colleagues at
NBA suggested that just one in four
Americans would like Joe Biden to run
again just one in four seventy percent
of Americans polled do not want Joe
Biden to run again that of course
includes Democrats many of whom voted
for him last time they reckon someone
else should take over uh the problem is
that there is no one else there there
are a few of the candidates from last
time around
um uh like Kamala Harris have been
strategically wrapped into team Biden
and haven't in fact shown all that much
so there aren't any obvious candidates
there were a few you post Biden
candidates people like Gavin Newsom from
California the governor there who'd like
to run if Biden's down to the side but
no one is prepared to stand in Biden's
way at the moment 2024 looks like a
repeat of 2020. Trump versus
and Mark you mentioned Kamal Harris
there of course she's referenced in that
video likely that she would stand for
vice president
no that's interesting I mean I haven't I
I just heard the video on my ear I
didn't see it um yes I mean if she is
I'm like yeah I'm just looking down here
it does look like there she is I mean
that's another big question who would he
who would he choose uh to be his running
mate
um she is all on obvious answer
potentially um but there have been
rumors over the course the past four
years at times that they haven't
necessarily seen eye to eye she has not
shown in a way that many expected that
she might
um she has been a disappointment for
many Democrats
um but uh clearly he believes it was
then if if she's in the video he
believes that maybe it is a a Biden
Harris ticket for 2024 as well we'll see
and Mark just looking at the tone of
that video as well you talked about the
age and the fact that he is a very
different man to to the man who even
stood just you know just sort of four
six years ago this difference in style
very quietly spoken do you think you
know is is that deliberate in the in the
sense that if it is Trump who does run
against him it's almost highlighting
this difference in style from the very
very beginning
yeah very much so I mean Trump is still
there Trump is still loud he's Brash uh
and this uh I mean Joe Biden is a softly
spoken person anyway and he is that much
older and therefore naturally he might
be a little bit softer still uh and and
they're using that to his Advantage uh
they are saying that he is the calm
Steady Hand uh that needs to continue to
be on the tiller to run uh America for
another four years because Joe uh
because Donald Trump um is there in in
the wings and owns the Republican Party
make no mistake
um despite the the Insurrection January
the sick featured of course prominently
in this video despite the fact that he
hasn't is now the first ever indicted uh
president Donald Trump still commands
the Republican Party he is very likely
to be their nomination uh their
candidate there are others Ron DeSantis
and others as well but at the moment it
looks like that it will be Donald Trump
that loud brash
um love him or hate him uh candidates
and so on the other side in this very
highly produced video uh which is um
framing it a choice as one of personal
Liberty uh that that is what um what
team Biden is going for but as I say
Jane overriding all of that is a a
simple concern that many many people
have is he too old
and and the 70 polling that that
suggests that 70 of Americans don't want
him to run again obviously including
Democrats as you say
um he is running again he says you know
if if he gets the the Democratic
nomination you know as as is likely that
will that change will Democrats get
behind him
well exactly because the second question
after that is okay he is running again
whether you like it or not so your
choice is Biden or Trump well obviously
um many of those people polled who said
they didn't want Biden to run uh will
but will vote for him in the end because
they absolutely do not want Trump to run
to win and that I think is the calculus
within team Biden as I said they know uh
that yes his age is a fact but so too is
the fact that he beat Trump last time
around although Trump continues to claim
without any evidence that he actually
won the last election Biden beat Trump
last time around and that's his big
um uh plus he believes he did it once he
could do it again the other calculus
that I think they're making and then
within the Biden White House is it
cannot be the case so they will argue
that Donald Trump is more popular now
given what we now know about him whether
it be the the documents he he hid the
Insurrection the indictment Trump can't
be more popular now than he was four
years ago and he lost four years ago
therefore by and surely is in a great
position to win this time around well I
mean yes that that might seem logical
but nothing is predictable in American
politics so it's a risky logic um with
it with a very elderly man